so what i want you to do is pause this
video and think about what fraction the
red part represents in each of these i
guess each of these shapes or what
fraction of the whole does the red part
represent and i also want you to plot it
out on a number line to plot that
fraction as a number on a number line
so let's go through each of these so in
this pi right over here we have one two
three four five equal sections and one
of those five equal sections is shaded
in so we could say that one fifth
of this pie is shaded in
now over here we have one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
equals sections and two of them are
shaded in so we could say that two
tenths
are shaded in
and then finally right over here once
again we have one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten equal sections
ten equal sections and two of them are
shaded in red so in this situation the
red of the red slices represent two
tenths of the whole
and if we were to try to plot this on a
number line so right over here let me do
a quick one right over here
let me
let me do it like this
let me make a big number line here
and let's take the section
between
0 and 1. that's what we want to focus on
and i'm going to divide it into 5 equal
sections so 1
5 equal sections and then that gets us
to 1. so this right over here 1
that would be
one out of the five equal sections so
that would get us right over there so
this would be
one fifth now what i want to do let me
copy and paste this same number line
since i've already drawn it so copy and
paste it so let me put it right over
here
but now i'm going to divide it into 10
equal sections so if we take let's see
let me divide it into 10 equal sections
on the top one so 1
10. so i've divided it into 10 equal
sections and i want to figure out where
two tenths goes
so i'm gonna go two of those equal
sections so one
two
so once again i've got to that exact
same point so this one-fifth i could
also represent as two over ten so i
could represent this as 2 over 10 this
point right over here and you might be
saying hey wait but that means that
those are the same number they're the
exact same point on the number line and
if you said that you would be absolutely
correct one-fifth
is equal to two tenths they represent
the exact same number and it makes sense
even when you visually look at them as a
fraction of these pies here going from
this this slice to this slice if you
were to just if you were to just divide
all of these slices into two
if you just divide all of these slices
into two you see that you have the exact
same fraction you have the exact same
fraction
shaded in as this one right over here
they've become identical i didn't shade
in anything else i haven't taken any of
the red away i haven't added any of the
red i just divided all of those all of
those pieces of pie into two and so you
see that the exact same part of the
whole pie is shaded in
and here it's not quite as obvious but
if you imagine taking this dividing it
into two
and then splitting them up so that they
look like this you still have the same
part of the circle you still have the
same part of the circle shaded in red so
it makes complete sense that they
represent the same number on the number
line that this number right over here
it's not only one-fifth it also
is two tenths one-fifth is equal to
two-tenths